And finally...
New rule, someone has to
convince President Biden
that if he runs again,
he's going to turn the country
back over to Trump,
-and go--
-(SOFT CLAPPING)
-(LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And go down in history
as Ruth Bader Biden.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
The person who doesn't know
when to quit,
and so does great damage to
their party and their country.
All of us who like Joe Biden
have been struggling lately
with the political situation
of the Democratic Party.
An incumbent we admire,
who acquitted himself well
in a first term,
but who even members
of his own party
don't want to see run
for a second.
Despite a touching letter
of recommendation
from Ashton Kutcher
and Mila Kunis.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
I kid. They shouldn't
have gotten shit for that.
If you ask me
do I think Joe Biden
can do the job of president,
my answer is an unequivocal
"Yes, he can do the job."
Do I love everything, no.
But that's every president.
But government work is done
in small, quiet rooms
like the Oval Office,
and in that setting,
Joe's compassion
and centuries of experience...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...are pluses.
And he's generally made
good decisions
that got us out of Afghanistan,
handled Ukraine,
kept the economy chugging,
finally got us rebuilding
infrastructure,
returned a sense of normalcy.
There's a term for Joe Biden.
But not two.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
Because while he can do the job,
what he can't do is run for it.
Our campaign season is long,
and it gets icy
in New Hampshire.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
To those who say he beat
Trump once, he'll do it again,
I say, things change.
They always do.
The parade moves on.
2024 is not 2020
in so many key ways,
including, yes,
Biden being four years older.
You can be a national treasure
and still be
too old for the job.
If I'm on a plane
and the pilot says,
"This is your captain,
Buzz Aldrin..."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-...I'm getting off.
(APPLAUSE)
Mitch McConnell
has served Satan well.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
But when he starts buffering
during a speech...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...and it appears his soul
is leaving his body...
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
...it's time.
I have made it a theme
on this show
to rail against ageism,
the last acceptable prejudice
in America.
I've tried to make the argument
that judging by age is wrong
because we all age
so differently.
Some people are old
when they're 45,
and others are spry at 90.
So it should always be
a case-by-case basis.
But the credibility
of my argument against ageism
rests on the honest calling out
of people when it is time to go.
That's what
"case by case" means.
At an event last weekend,
Biden referred to LL Cool J
as LL J Cool J.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Say what you want about Trump,
but he remembers Kanye's name.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Look, at some point,
perception becomes reality.
What matters is voters think
Biden's too old.
What matters is
he's gonna lose to Trump,
who's almost the same age,
but his age just doesn't
read like Biden's.
Maybe it's because
Trump is insane,
maybe it's because he's always
a ball of white-hot anger,
but for whatever reason,
he looks robust,
and Joe looks like
his own skeletal remains.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
If this was 1860,
when Joe first ran...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...this would not be an issue.
You didn't have to look good,
and there was no
ubiquitous media
to pick on every little mistake.
The only people who saw
the Lincoln-Douglas debates
were the people
who went to them.
But Joe's debates next year
will be televised to all,
and I don't think
he's gonna look good.
Yes, Trump is old too,
but Trump is like KISS.
He puts on the face paint
and the wig...
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
...and he looks the same
as he did in 1978.
Far from being the only one
who could beat Trump in 2024,
Biden may well be the only
Democrat who would lose to him.
James Carville told me
any centers Democrat
around 50 or 60
would get 55 percent
of the vote,
and I believe him.
You know that
Future Headlines bit we do?
Well, the most predictable
headline ever is,
"Presidential Race Tied."
Two weeks before every election,
it's always tied,
no matter who is running.
The vast majority just vote
for the D or the R.
But Biden is the one Democrat
who gives pause
to so many people,
even in his own party.
Andrew Sullivan
makes the necessary point
that a new nominee
for the Democrats
would shift
the dynamic immediately.
Trump would be the tired old guy
retread hanging onto the past,
and the Democrat
would now be the future.
Let the Republicans be
the party with the candidate
who babbles nonsense,
shouts at the TV,
and can't do ramps.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
Joe, you did noble service
for your country,
and you checked that big box,
the President
of the United States.
Of course, as a politician,
you're naturally gonna say,
"But the work is not finished."
Of course not, it never is.
But it's time to let
someone else finish it.
You don't want to go down
as Ruth Bader Biden.
America is calling, Joe,
and it's saying,
"That's not our car, grandpa,
we're over here."